one of my top priorities over the next 24 to 96
hours is the safety of everybody in our audience,
of people all over the United States is there is
a lot of unrest expected in the U.S. and in fact,
police departments across the country as well as
D.C. police are expecting protests and unrest.
We've seen police departments scale up the
availability of crowd suppression tools. We've
seen businesses board up windows in many parts of
the country. I've talked already about some of the
advice from universities, from travel departments
under the departments of State. In other countries
like New Zealand and Australia, etc. But it is
also Donald Trump who will be barricading himself
behind a massive new non scalable fence today
at the White House. CNN and NBC News are now
reporting that a supposedly non scalable fence
will be placed around the White House in time
for the start of election results tonight.
These will be similar barriers to those that
went up around the White House in June during the
police brutality protests. ICE officers are being
put on standby. Customs and Border Protection
is issuing extra training on crowd control.
National Guard troops are on standby. And remember
that originally Donald Trump was planning this big
election night party at his Washington, D.C.
hotel. Why not make some money by hiring his own
business to host the party? We learned yesterday
and talked about it on yesterday's bonus show that
that party has been canceled. And instead,
Donald Trump is going to be hunkering down
at the White House where he will reportedly hold
and indoor election night party. But, of course,
the suspicion really is twofold.
On the one hand, the big party at the hotel
maybe has been canceled because the Trump campaign
is no longer expecting a win or at least maybe
no longer expects a credible, definitive win
tonight as more votes will remain to be counted.
But number two, in addition to that, the security
concerns make it preferable to keep Donald Trump
at the White House behind a series of
concentric fences. And the suspicion, of course,
is that Donald Trump, from his White House bunker
behind a new fence, will claim victory tonight,
even if there is no actual victory visible in
the data that we have. By midnight tonight and
then in will come Donald Trump's lawyers
and they will try to stop the counting of
absentee ballots not yet received by midnight
tonight. You don't have to take my word for it.
Here is Donald Trump himself saying this is
what he plans to do because it can only lead to
one thing, and that's very bad. You know what
that thing is? I think it's a very dangerous,
terrible thing. And I think it's terrible when
we can't know the results of an election the
night of the election and a modern day computer. I
think it's a terrible thing. And I happen to think
it was a terrible decision for our country made
by the Supreme Court. I think it was a terrible
decision for our country. And I think it's a very
dangerous decision because you're going to have
one or two or three states, depending on how it
ends up with a tabulating ballot. And the rest
of the world is waiting to find out. And I think
there's great danger to do it. And I think a lot
of fraud and misuse could take place. I think
it's a terrible decision by the Supreme Court,
a terrible decision. I don't know if that's
going to be change because we're going to go
in that night as soon as that election's
over. We're going in with our lawyers,
but we don't want to have Pennsylvania, where you
have a political governor, a very partizan guy.
So there it is. I mean, no no need to wonder
about what the plan is. We just need to be
ready. And I hope Biden's lawyers are ready now at
this point. I wouldn't even be shocked if Donald
Trump declares victory before all the votes
are counted. I wouldn't be shocked if Trump
undermines the credibility of the results or says
Joe Biden couldn't possibly have won, if that's
indeed what happens. But we are looking now in
all seriousness, at major nationwide protests.
If Donald Trump tries funny business
and if courts start going along with it,
we are going to see mass gatherings, the likes of
which this country has not seen for a long time.
That doesn't mean Trump will fail to
use the courts to steal the election.
That's still a concern, which we have to hope
Joe Biden and the Democratic Party are ready for
and prepared to fight back against. If we have
a simple election. And Donald Trump just loses,
it will be a very different type of
chaos. And we may see armed right wingers
may be operating under the umbrella of being
a so-called militia. And that's very scary.
But the optics of Trump putting up a fence and
barricading himself at the White House is both.
Metaphorical for what many of us believe he will
try to do if he loses tonight, hold on to power.
But it is also very similar to the behavior we've
seen from authoritarian dictators around the world
close to the end of their reigns. Trump has said,
I may leave the country if I lose. Trump said,
too. I think it was Michigan last night. I will
never come back to Michigan if I lose. Trump
is going to stay at the White House and put
new fencing around him. Trump is going to try
to use the courts to retain power. These are the
actions of authoritarian dictators, the world over
over the last hundred plus years. Let's just hope
that this is the beginning of the end rather than
the halfway point in Donald Trump's reign. That
would be exhausting. That would be exhausting.
If that were to be the case, if we're only halfway
through right now, that is some very ugly stuff.